le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
veiller au bon déroulement de la vie du
collège c'est la mission quotidienne d
att les adjoints techniques territoriaux
des établissements d'enseignement ces
agents du département s'occupe de tâches
aussi variés que les espaces verts
l'accueil ou la restauration rencontre
avec rené claude et elisabeth qui nous
présentent leur métier
[Musique]
il est près de six heures du matin la
cour du collège du 14e est encore bien
vide
et pourtant quelqu'un commence sa
journée un peu avant les autres
le soufflet recoupent fille taille des
fleurs avant même l'arrivée des premiers
élèves l'accord est comme neuf
de bon matin j'arrive à faire le tout la
porte yves du collège souffleur
physiquement de en général j'ai tout ce
qui s'appelle les fleurs déjà j'ai eu
toute la cour à entretenir
c'est l'idéal pour moi le matin rené
claude est un att adjoint technique
territorial des établissements
d'enseignement avec 13 autres collègues
il veille au bon fonctionnement de
l'établissement en mission s'est donnée
aux élèves le ski à 2-2 propre au niveau
du du 14e csu à tous de faire comprendre
qu'on est là on veut les aider aussi
dans toutes nos tâches parmi ces
activités
l'agencé pris d'intérêt pour les plates
bandes fleuries je reçois en ville je
voyais souvent il ya des plantes qui
sont très jolies j'ai proposé ça au
principal d'un côté le principal m'a dit
pourquoi pas et j'ai appris ça ici c'est
un envie de moi même j'avais fait des
propositions ça a été intercepté à j'ai
même des profs qui sont venus en temps
vers moi en me disant que monsieur vous
avez fait beaucoup de travail c'est très
joli pour le collège je suis très fier
de moi de mon travail au niveau du
collège 14e dehors dans les sanitaires
les salles de classe la multiplicité des
tâches nécessitent une équipe soudée
déjà ce qui me plaît le plus et
l'environnement c'est un groupe qui est
de souder qui est bien entre nous j'ai
toujours préféré travailler dans cet
environnement la cccc tellement
intéressant on apprend de tout dans ce
collège on a une équipe très sympa en
tant qu'employé des collèges les rtt
sont sous la responsabilité du
département de la réunion
si on n'a pas des tpe on n'a pas de
fonctionnement établissements ils sont
au nombre d'un peu plus de 1000 agents
que nous gérons nous au sein de
l'académie de la réunion
dans les collèges de la réunion et je
peux vous assurer que s'ils ne sont pas
là l'établissement ne fonctionne pas
c'est lui qui fait le nettoyage c'est
lui qui travaille en restauration
scolaire c'est lui qui gère
l'environnement tout ce qui est
l'hygiène et sécurité dans son
établissement en tous les cas au collège
mais d'abord donné l'accueil bonjour oui
je vous écoute madame donnez moi le nom
et la classe s'il vous plaît tout comme
rené claude elisabeth et att
mais ces spécialisations est tout autre
je suis agent chargé principalement de
l'accueil donc qui dit accueil dick
accueil des visiteurs des enseignants
des élèves également donc accueil
téléphonique également chaque matin il
faut distribuer aux enseignants des clés
parmi les 200 sous sa responsabilité une
organisation qu'elle a elle même mis en
place bonjour plus gros du travail
consiste surtout à la gestion des clés
donc distribution des clés pour les
enseignants que c'est moi qui ai mis en
place toute la gestion
à mon arrivée toute la gestion de ces
clés le l'organisation donc avec le
temps
dix ans maintenant la diversité des
missions et les nouvelles rencontres
sont au coeur de ce métier ce qui me
plaît c'est surtout le contact
et puis c'est pouvoir rencontrer pas mal
de personnes et puis surtout avoir
plusieurs
plusieurs petites tâches à accomplir
donc ce qui fait que les journées ne se
ressemblent pas mon émission ce n'est
pas uniquement faire de l'accueil
téléphonique et physique
c'est aussi pouvoir faciliter la tâche
on va dire des uns et des autres même
journée merci
[Musique]
les adjoints techniques territoriaux des
établissements d'enseignement sont
placés sous la tutelle du département
leur polyvalence est essentiel
fonctionnement de l'établissement
ils sont plus de 1000 agents sur l'île
cet emploi couvrent divers corps de
métiers aussi variés que chauffeur
bûcheron cuisinier le sens du contact
est primordial dans ce métier mais
également la technicité et la rigueur on
y accède par recrutement direct ou par
concours pour plus de renseignements
rendez vous sur le site du département
au www.pc.ca de quatre point fr lien
social accompagne le réunionnais pour la
mobilité
je m'appelle amandine mariage j'ai 21
ans cette année et r j'habite à sainte
suzanne et je suis venu ici pour faire
un bac pro commerce en alimentation
à la réunion c'est bien mais c'est
compliqué d'avoir une formation interne
ans comment l'école elle est plutôt
ouverte qu'aux paiements mais les
entreprises c'est plus compliqué bon moi
comme j'étais à la réunion avec ma maman
ma famille et moi ça m'a permis de
grandir
franchement sur un point d'être
responsable de gérer un budget d'
apprendre plein de choses je me voyais
pas franchement là dans dix ans à
draguignan marseille dans les terres oui
soit ce gens c'est un moment donné dans
la nuit et avec le temps on s'adapte et
ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
non